aujourd'hui dans l'actuelle combat
d'isabelle mère de famille de plaisir
dont la fille est lourdement handicapée
elle attend un logement adapté la
proposition faite par son bailleur
social ne lui convient pas elle compte
entamer une grève de la faim comment
remettre sur le marché de l'emploi des
personnes qui ont quitté depuis
plusieurs années le monde du travail
tout l'objectif d'un forum à destination
des bénéficiaires du rsa la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vend ses biens
en ligne tables chaises armoires les
biens sont estimés entre 5 et 600 euros
il faut faire vite la vente se clôture
ce vendredi une journée dédiée à
l'archéologie aux archives
départementales à montigny le bretonneux
clou de la visite à l'anthropologie
physique ou l'étude des restes humains
il y a quatre ans la fille d'isabelle a
développé une maladie orpheline qui
l'obligent à se déplacer désormais en
fauteuil roulant aujourd'hui âgé de 24
ans ludivine termine fin juin un séjour
d'un an dans un centre de rééducation du
val d'oise et devra donc réintégré le
domicile familial problème l'appartement
qu'occupe actuellement isabelle et ses
deux autres enfants à plaisir n'est pas
adapté aux personnes en fauteuil on
aurait besoin d'un f4 même peut-être f5
adapté aux personnes handicapées c'est à
dire rez-de-chaussée ou alors avec
ascenseur afin que ludivine puy se
sortir et rentrer librement de
l'appartement isabelle a multiplié les
demandes de logement auprès du centre
communal d'action de plaisir de la
mairie des sociétés hlm et de la
préfecture des yvelines le maire a
appelé un petit peu ma demande en en
envoyant des courriers divers courriers
aux sociétés d'intérim qui sont sur
plaisir et à la préfecture des yvelines
mais rien ne bouge quoi son bailleur
social l'opievoy a bien proposé de les
reloger à plaisir mais elle a décliné
l'offre personnellement je
n'habiteraient pas ovale et vous voilà
je me sens pas en sécurité dans mener
mes deux filles dans un secteur de
plaisir comme le valais vaud isabelle a
aussi demandé le soutien de
l'association des paralysés de france et
pour se faire entendre elle est prête à
entamer dès ce vendredi f de la fin
pas facile de trouver ont retrouvé un
travail quand on touche le rsa chômage
de longue durée ou isolement peuvent
corse et le retour à l'emploi pour
débloquer la situation le premier job
dating dédié à la réinsertion
professionnelle a été organisée à la
maison de l'emploi de plaisir il ya des
entreprises des centres de formation des
organismes aussi de réinsertion
professionnelle donc ils peuvent
répondre au retour à l'emploi point
essentiel ces structures sont un
tremplin pour ces demandeurs d'emploi
ici on ne vient pas chercher un cdi
exemple avec cette structure d'insertion
qui recherchent trois agents de tri on
propose des contrats d'insertion qui ont
un agrément maximum de 12 ans au cours
de ces deux ans les gens passent par
différentes étapes en fait il se
réadapte ils sont des repères et puis
gagne en rapidité voilà les notes après
ils sont prêts pour retrouver un autre
emploi dans une autre entreprise dit
classique en fait c'est très utile sa
compagne beaucoup les gens je prends ça
au niveau de l'emploi là j'ai repéré la
structure rapides elles pour pouvoir
commencer à partir du mois de septembre
dans leur passage sur les 500 personnes
invitées à rencontrer la quinzaine
d'entreprises du territoire plus de la
moitié a répondu présentes une deuxième
édition devrait bientôt être organisé
toujours en partenariat avec pôle emploi
la communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines a décidé de vendre
aux enchères quelques biens sur internet
300 produits sont destinés à la vente
parmi lesquels armoires tables chaises
et bureaux on a des postes
on va dire de collaborateurs dans
différentes tailles 160 ou 180 on a des
plans de travail tout seul des plans de
travail complet avec des questions on à
du mobilier de direction donc certaines
gammes selon les années à certains prix
comptez par exemple 600 euros pour ce
bureau contre 50 ou 30 pour d'autres
modèles 7,27 landes en quatre vagues et
la première déjà achevés s'adressait
seulement aux agents de la communauté
d'agglomération et aux associations
saint-quentinoise sur 150 objets mis aux
enchères 56 ont été achetés par 17
collaborateurs de l'agglomération et
huit associations quant à la deuxième
qui se fermera vendredi elle concerne
tous les publics et pour les
retardataires deux autres phases sont
encore prévues pour les mois de juillet
et septembre on est un peu dans l'idée
que cette troisième vague se termine on
veut dire la fin du mois de juillet pour
un horizon et à partir de là septembre
constituera la quatrième vague et on
espère la dernière le château de la
coudre ancien siège de l'agglomération
accueille actuellement le mobilier à
vendre une fois vidé le bâtiment devrait
être transformé en résidence pour
personnes âgées
journée portes ouvertes au centre des
archives départementales d'archéologie
située à montigny samedi dernier les
visiteurs ont pu choisir entre une
exposition du temps de vercingétorix à
charlemagne dans les yvelines mais le
clou de la visite l'anthropologie
physique ou l'étude des restes humains
avec des squelettes plutôt bien
conservée comme celui ci de l'époque
mérovingienne
ce squelette
en examinant les autres son bassin on
nous dit qu'il est est un homme
voilà en regardant en fait les traces
on peut voir sur les vertèbres
on peut en conclure que l'homme est un
individu assez âgées élément important
qui aident à déterminer la tranche d'âge
du squelette à sa mort sa dentition
qu'ici on à la mandibule d'un individu
qui est donc immature un enfant on voit
qu'il n'a plus aucune tente l'est mais
que ses dents à définitive ne sont pas
encore tous pousser et à partir de ça
donc on voit que la première molaire est
là mais la deuxième n'est pas encore
sorti les canines l'enflure donc on peut
en déduire qu'il avait entre 10 et 12
ans on peut presque tout savoir de la
vie d'un humain via ses restes et les
séquelles qu'il a eu pendant sa vie
témoin de la dureté de l'existence à
l'époque la présence de fracture comme
je voulais montrer tout à l'heure c'est
signale par un calot ce sur lost nous
donc nous voyons ici nous clavicule qui
n'a pas subi deux traumatismes et de
l'autre côté une clavicule qui a été
fracturée donc comme la fracture n'a pas
été très bien réduite l'os au lieu de se
ressouder dans son prolongement ses
chevauchées et s'est soudé dans cette
position ou sinon donc là
décarie qui ont complètement détruit
détruit les molaires la première et la
deuxième molaires est tombée les caries
ont entraîné la création d'un abcès et
parfois les ossements révèle des
pratiques encore inexpliquées même
aujourd'hui la sur le côté on peut voir
une trépanation une trépanation est une
ouverture volontaire sur le crâne ans on
en 6è le cuir chevelu pour dégager l'os
avec un silex et avec ce même si l'ex on
aller gratter l'os jusqu'à arriver
au cerveau les portes ouvertes sont
terminées mais l'exposition de
vercingétorix à charlemagne est encore
visible jusqu'au 29 juin
après venise vivaldi versailles le
château de versailles accueille m del
sur le grand canal pour ces fêtes de
nuit une dalle est un compositeur
baroque comme vivaldi dont là on va dire
la période est la même que celle du
château de versailles mais c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a composé de manière
géniale pour le plein air et c'était ce
plein air qui nous intéresse ce soir
pour ces feux royaux deux chefs-d'oeuvre
d'emden mise en lumière water music
interprété en 1717 pour le roi
d'angleterre sur une barque remontant la
tamise et royal fireworks musiques
composées en 1749 est joué par de la
célébration de la bête aix la chapelle
deux classiques fait sur mesure pour le
domaine de louis xiv
le décor du grand canal est désormais
bien connue du groupe f qui signe les
fêtes royal de versailles depuis de
nombreuses années malgré l'habitude de
traque de la première ne disparaît pas
c'est encore pire que la première fois
c'est c'est toujours des spectacles très
très compliqué il faut que ça faut que
ça ait l'air simple jeu soit magique et
en même temps derrière il ya évidemment
des montagnes de techniques de time code
de don de 2 wifi pour que tout ça
fonctionne tout ensemble donc on est
toujours très peur que là que la
technique tout lâche la technique et le
temps deux éléments déterminants pour
les spectacles pyrotechniques qui allie
flamme feux d'artifice lasers et
hologram
cette année on n'est plus avec d'autres
créateurs dont il ya claude l'ifa qui
vient pour la création laser il ya
michel amman
qui vient pour la création fontaine et
pour le reste c'est les arguments du
groupe f dans la partie théâtrale et
lumière et on a créé comme ça de trois
très belles surprises et parmi les
surprises réservées au public ce grands
bateaux illuminés naviguant sur les
flots est-ce que vous avez préféré le
bateau le grand bateau avec avec louis
sursaut tout ce temps c'est exceptionnel
si c'est trop bien qu'est ce qui t'a plu
le plus bas à la fin mais pourquoi pas
parce que ça faisait trop de bruit et
ben moi et je me suis moqué dans ma tête
parce qu'elle s'était boucher les
oreilles
les feux d'artifice royaux et leur
impressionnant bouquet final embrassons
le grand canal jusqu'au 6 juillet quatre
représentations